-Guys, as you know, I have a new
children's book out.
"Nana Loves You More,"
and it just came out this week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It just came out this week,
and I was excited.
We had Nana-themed week
and all sorts of talented
grandmas came, and it was
awesome and I loved it.
It just got announced today
that we are number one on
"The New York Times" best-seller
list.
Come on!
[ Applause ]
Number one, baby.
-Best-seller.
-I'm just so psyched about that.
Look, it's very thin.
-Right.
-You know, and it looks like no
work went into this.
-Right, but...
-Well, you know,
I did put some work into it.
-Yeah.
-Figuring out the end?
-I'm figuring out --
-Have you won it?
-No, but look at this.
This thing,
it took two years to make.
And I'm serious.
It did.
Because you come up
with the idea,
I go, "Oh, yeah.
I want to do something
for grandmas out there."
And so you write --
I had like one good line.
I go, "Okay, that's good."
And it's a little weepy.
-Right.
-It's a nice little sad one.
Not too weepy...
-No.
-... that you're like bawling.
Because I have those books too,
and I have to ban them
from my house
because I don't like them
for me or my child.
-Don't want them reading them?
-No, I'm just like,
"[ Crying ]
And then I love you."
[ Normal voice ] And then I go,
"I can't do that."
But this one, you go,
"Oh, this rhymes with that,"
and then I got to be super
creative,
and then we had a great artist
and they make animals
and the drawings
and all the stuff.
And then you send it back
and give notes,
and then you have to send it,
and they have to make it
and it takes two years.
So it's like wow.
You're like I remember spending
every single day,
and now it's finally out.